THEY ARE STICKING BY THAT.
>> Ed: KRISTIN FIESHER LIVE AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Sandra: A FOURTH CORONAVIRUS
RELIEF PACKAGE FACING A SETBACK
ON THE HILL.
REPUBLICANS ARGUING THE FIRST
BILL PASSED SHOULD MAKE AN
IMPACT BEFORE LAWMAKERS MOVE
FORWARD WITH ANY MORE
LEGISLATION.
DEMOCRATS DISAGREE.
>> I THINK IMMEDIATE AID TO
AMERICANS IS WHAT IS CRITICAL
AND I THINK THAT’S WHAT THE
SPEAKER IS FOCUSED ON.
THERE IS NO QUESTION WE HAVE TO
DO MORE.
THE STIMULUS THAT WE HAVE PUT
OUT IS CERTAINLY GOOD BUT SO
MUCH OF THAT MONEY IS NOT GOING
TO BE RECEIVED BY INDIVIDUALS
FOR WEEKS, MAYBE EVEN MONTHS.
>> Sandra: JOINING US IS
WYOMING SENATOR JOHN BARRASSO.
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE
REPUBLICAN CONFERENCE AND
MEDICAL DOCTOR AS WELL.
GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU, SANDRA.
>> Sandra: SO DO YOU BELIEVE
THAT A FOURTH STIMULUS BILL
WILL BE NEEDED?
>> BEFORE GETTING TO THAT LET
ME FIRST SAY AS A DOCTOR AND
SENATOR I WANT TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE ARE TAKEN CARE OF IN
TERMS OF THEIR HEALTH AND
WELL-BEING.
THIS WILL BE A CRITICAL AND
CRUCIAL WEEK IN AMERICA.
THE MORE PEOPLE CAN DO TO STAY
AT HOME, TO WASH THEIR HANDS
FREQUENTLY, AVOID TOUCHING
THEIR FACE THE BETTER IT IS
GOING TO BE.
WITH REGARD TO A FOURTH
STIMULUS I SPOKE TO THE
PRESIDENT AND SENATOR MCCONNELL
THIS WEEK.
FIRST WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS LAST BILL THE CARES ACT
ACTUALLY WORKS TO GET RELIEF TO
THE PEOPLE THAT NEED IT, WHICH
IS JUST ABOUT EVERYBODY IN
AMERICA.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS GET WHAT
THEY NEED AND TO MAKE SURE OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE ABLE TO
GET THESE LOANS.
WE PUT OUT 17,000 LOANS
ALREADY, ABOUT $5 BILLION.
THERE IS $350 BILLION IN THE
PROJECT.
WITH REGARD TO A FOURTH PACKAGE
I BELIEVE THERE WILL BE ONE BUT
I HAVE TO TELL YOU THERE IS NO
WAY THAT NANCY PELOSI CAN ONCE
AGAIN BRING TO THAT HER LIST OF
LIBERAL LEFTIST APPROACHES OF
THE GREEN NEW DEAL AND ELECTION
REFORM.
THINGS SHE IS TALKING ABOUT.
ABOUT DIVERSITY OF CORPORATE
BOARDS.
THIS IS A CRISIS THAT OUR
COUNTRY IS FACING.
ANYTHING IN THIS FOURTH PACKAGE
HAS TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
FULFILLED THE NEEDS THAT WE
PROMISED WOULD BE MET THROUGH
THE THIRD PACKAGE.
>> Sandra: IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU
AGREE WITH MITCH MCCONNELL IN
THE WAIT AND SEE APPROACH WITH
WITH THE FIRST THREE ROUNDS OF
STIMULUS THAT WITH THAT WAS
BIPARTISAN.
HOW DO YOU KEEP THE APPROACH TO
RELIEF FOR AMERICANS BIPARTISAN
WHEN CLEARLY NANCY PELOSI IS
MAKING THE CASE FOR MORE
STIMULUS AND MITCH MCCONNELL
SAYING HOLD ON, LET’S WAIT AND
SEE.
>> WE ACTUALLY HAD THAT PROCESS
IN A VERY BIPARTISAN WAY IN THE
SENATE BEFORE NANCY PELOSI CAME
IN WITH THIS BIG LIBERAL WISH
LIST.
NOW SHE IS TRYING IT AGAIN WITH
PHASE FOUR WHERE SHE WANTS TAX
BREAKS FOR MILLIONAIRES IN THE
BLUE STATES.
WELL, THAT’S NOT GOING TO CUT
IT EITHER.
IF WE GET TO A PHASE FOUR AND
WE’RE AT A POINT WHERE WE’RE
BEYOND IN AND HAVE THE DISEASE
BEHIND US AND STIMULATE THE
ECONOMY.
ONE THING WE’VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT IS THE INFRASTRUCTURE
BILL.
A BILL THAT CAME OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE THAT
PASSED 21-0 EVERY REPUBLICAN,
EVERY DEMOCRAT HAS VOTED FOR IT.
WE OUGHT TO STICK WITH THE
BIPARTISAN THINGS THAT WORK
RATHER THAN THE SORT OF THINGS
THAT NANCY PELOSI IS TRYING TO
BRING TO THE TABLE TO TAKE THE
COUNTRY IN A DIRECTION THAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SAY LET’S DEAL
WITH THE CRISIS THAT IS
AFFECTING US RIGHT NOW.
>> Sandra: WELL, SENATOR, YOU
DO COME AT THIS FROM A UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE ALSO BEING A
MEDICAL DOCTOR AS WELL AS A
U.S. SENATOR.
DR. FAUCI WAS WARNING AGAINST
THE DANGERS OF THOSE STATES WHO
HAVE NOT IMPLEMENTED COMPLETE
STAY AT HOME ORDERS, WYOMING IS
ONE OF THEM.
HERE IS DR. FAUCI.
>> THE TENSION BETWEEN
FEDERALLY MANDATED VERSUS
STATES RIGHTS TO DO WHAT THEY
WANT IS SOMETHING I DON’T WANT
TO GET INTO.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT’S GOING ON
IN THIS COUNTRY I DON’T
UNDERSTAND WHY WE’RE NOT DOING
THAT.
WE REALLY SHOULD BE.
>> Sandra: IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT SHOULD BE CONSIDERED FOR
YOUR STATE?
>> YOU CAN ALWAYS DEPEND ON THE
PEOPLE OF WYOMING TO DO THE
RIGHT THING.
WE HAVE A STATE OF EMERGENCY IN
WYOMING.
ANYONE COMING INTO OUR STATE
THERE IS A 14-DAY QUARANTINE.
PEOPLE ARE STAYING AT HOME.
REMEMBER, PEOPLE ARE SPREAD OUT
HERE.
WE ONLY HAVE FIVE PEOPLE PER
SQUARE MILE AND SOCIALLY
DISTANCING THE ENTIRE 130 YEARS
WE’VE BEEN A STATE.
WE SURVIVED BY PEOPLE HELPING
PEOPLE, NEIGHBOR HELPING
NEIGHBOR.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE 200 CASES.
NO DEATHS.
WE HOPE TO KEEP IT THAT WAY BY
CONTINUING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING.
>> Sandra: WHAT’S THE RISK OR
HARM IN ISSUING THE STAY AT
HOME ORDER STATEWIDE?
>> WELL, PEOPLE ARE STAYING AT
HOME IN WYOMING SO IT IS BEING
DONE ALREADY.
I THINK THE GOVERNOR HAS STRUCK
THE RIGHT BALANCE.
THIS IS THE PEOPLE OF WYOMING
KNOW WHAT’S BEST IN WYOMING.
WE’LL CONTINUE TO DO THAT AND
CONTINUE TO FOLLOW ALL OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE THERE
IN WYOMING.
PEOPLE ARE REALLY STAYING HOME.
IF WE GO TO THE GROCERY STORE
PEOPLE ARE WEARING MASKS AND
KEEPING DISTANCES, SPECIAL
HOURS SET UP FOR SENIORS.
BUT IT IS A STATE WHERE
NEIGHBORS HELP NEIGHBORS AND
WE’LL CONTINUE TO DO IT THAT
WAY.
>> Sandra: THE SIGN OF UNITY IS
SOMETHING WE CAN ALL COME TO
APPRECIATE DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME FOR OUR COUNTRY.
APPRECIATE YOU COMING ON THE